[MUSIC PLAYING]
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
Hello, everyone.
Good morning.
Thanks for coming
to this session.
I'm Indranil Chakraborty.
I'm the product guy with
Google Cloud Platform.
And together with my colleagues
here, in this session
we're going to
cover three things.
One is the key
challenges for Edge.
And Google Cloud's offering
to address those challenges.
Second is, how are we, as Google
Cloud and Google in general,
thinking about offering
an integrated AI platform.
And finally, we'll have
some demos for you.
So let's get started.
So let's start with a
simple dictionary definition
of Internet of Things.
By the way, the computer
is not working here.
The Internet of Things, if
you look at the dictionary,
the definition is
interconnection
of computing devices
embedded in everyday things
via the internet.
Essentially, it
is everyday things
connected to the internet and,
hence, Internet of Things.
And in this path
of interconnection,
there are really three
interacting units.
There's a network
of objects that
connect wired or
wirelessly to internet,
and the network of
objects could be
devices, could be appliances,
cars, and so on and so forth.
Then, there are gateways
with access bridges
between these devices
and the internet.
And finally, Cloud,
where you want
to store the information
which you're receiving
from the devices and gateways
for processing it, and then
analyzing it to
derive intelligence.
As you all might
already know, that it
is estimated that by end of
2020 there'll be around $25
billion such install IT units.
And these IT units
would be installed
across the consumer segments as
well as the business segments.
So that's an enormous
number of devices
connected to the internet.
And we are already generating
more data than ever
with these Internet
of Thing devices,
and the data generation
is continuing to grow.
So when Google--
around last year,
we announced Cloud IoT
Core to really help
customers, enterprise
customers and developers,
to manage this massive
number of devices
and be able to
easily ingest influx
of data from these devices.
So Clout IoT Core is a
fully managed service
which allows you to
securely connect and manage
your devices on Google Cloud.
And since our
announcements last year,
the market reaction,
the reaction
from our customers and partner
has been really positive.
It has been phenomenal.
We have customers
in manufacturing,
in a Smart Parking management,
health care, oil and gas
services who are connecting
their assets on the field
to Google Cloud IoT
Core so that they
can connect to all these
devices securely and then
use the rest of our Google
Cloud Analytics and AI services
for ingesting storing data and
really deriving intelligence.
And as we started working
with Cloud IoT core,
our focus has been on
four critical areas.
One is intelligence.
So once you've collected all
this data from the installed
units, what do you
do with those data?
So we want to make sure
that we make it really easy
for you guys, for
customers and partners,
to derive intelligence from
the data that you collect.
Second is scale.
So Clout IoT Platform
and Cloud IoT Core
is a serverless service.
So whether you
connect one device,
or you connect
hundreds of thousands,
or even millions of devices,
you just connect your devices,
and we scale internally.
As a customer or
as a developer, you
don't have to worry about
adding new infrastructure
or adding a new VM instance
as you add more devices.
So we really have
focused on scale.
Third is security.
We wanted to make sure
that each IoT device there
can be individually
authenticated,
and it makes a secure
connection to Google Cloud.
And finally, we focused on
building up a robust partner
ecosystem.
So we've been working
really hard on these four
critical areas.
And we identified
early on that there
is an emergent need for
running local services close
to the devices itself, to
the Edge devices itself.
And in fact, all these
four critical areas
are relevant for
edge devices as well.
And most important of those four
was intelligence at the edge.
So lets take some
example use cases.
And if you have a camera
pointed at your parking lot,
where you're using the camera
to count real time the number
of cars that are parked
in the parking lot,
it's not really cost effective,
and it doesn't really makes
any sense to send every
frame of the video
from the camera to Cloud
to analyze and count
the number of cars that are
there in the parking lot.
What if you could just do
it in the camera itself?
If you have a
factory with robots,
they could be
regulatory reasons.
There could be reasons for which
you want to protect your IP,
and you don't want to send
all the data to Google Cloud.
You might want to filter some
of the data on the edge itself.
If you're doing
object detection using
a camera or some other
device, and there are,
for privacy reasons,
you may not want
to send all of the
sensitive data to Cloud
but you would want to run
some of those analyses
and intelligence on
the device itself.
So based on these, for
all these reasons before,
I'm very excited that we
announced two new products
for Edge computing
and Edge intelligence.
One is Cloud IoT Edge.
Cloud IoT Edge is
a software stack
which extends the AI and
data processing capabilities
of Google Cloud to the Edge.
And second is Edge TPU,
which is a Google-designed
high-performing hardware chip to
run machine learning inference
on the Edge device itself.
So let's get a little bit more
into the details of these two
products.
So with Cloud IoT
Edge, as I mentioned,
it's a software runtime that
you can run in your IoT gateway
devices.
You can run it on a camera.
You can run it on any
connected device that
has some compute capabilities,
essentially a device that
has a CPU.
And Cloud IoT Edge
software runtime
allows you to run machine
learning inference on the Edge
device itself.
It has built-in
support for Edge TPU,
so that you can have lightning
fast machine learning inference
on your device itself.
With Cloud IoT Edge, you
can also locally store
some of your data.
You can process it.
You can do translation.
You can do some
aggregation and filtration
before you send the
data back to Cloud
Android Things is one
of our, Google's, manage
operating system
for IoT devices,
which has got a secure boot.
So we have designed from ground
up for security and software
update.
And Cloud IoT Edge
runs on Android Things,
and we are planning to soon
have support for Linux versions
as well.
And it securely connects your
Edge devices to Google Cloud.
At the same time, we've
also added enhanced security
through hardware root of trust,
and Cloud IoT Edge seamlessly
works with Google
Cloud IoT Core and rest
of Google Cloud IoT Platform
for hassle free provisioning.
So it's a complete
software stack
to run machine learning
inference on the Edge device
itself.
And there are two
key components that
enables Cloud IoT Edge to--
for real time AI, on
the edge device itself.
There's a TensorFlow
Lite based runtime
that allows you to run those
machine learning inference
on the Edge, reducing
latency and then increasing
the versatility of
your Edge device.
And because we use TensorFlow
Lite runtime, which
is an open source, you
can use Cloud IoT Edge
with Edge TPU for
really lightning
fast and high-performing
performance.
But if you have a device which
doesn't have an Edge TPU,
or your use case doesn't require
the horsepower of an Edge TPU
chip, you can still
run Cloud IoT Edge
and do local inference on
your device, which has a GPU
or just has a CPU itself, so
it's pretty flexible that way.
And the second
component is IoT Core
that securely connects your
Edge device to Google Cloud.
So you can manage your software.
You can do software
and firmware updates.
You can exchange data
and also exchange
machine learning models between
your Edge device and the Cloud.
So combined with these two
key components, what Cloud IoT
Edge offers you is the software
runtime for running machine
learning inference, but also
to orchestrate your models
and data exchange
with Google Cloud.
Let's take an example.
Say you have a factory with a
high velocity assembly line,
and you want to detect
anomalies real time.
And you have a camera that
has our Edge TPU chip,
and it's running Android Things,
and it has our Cloud IoT Edge
software runtime running on it.
And you have collected
historical data
from your assembly line
production, which you can then
use which using Cloud
Machine Learning
Engine you can train a model
to accurately detect defects.
You can then push
down that model
to the camera via our Cloud
IoT Core and Cloud IoT Edge
software.
And using Edge
TPU, now you can do
real time detection of anomaly
on your high velocity assembly.
So with Cloud IoT edge as
a software, and Edge TPU
chip as our hardware
chip, together
with our Cloud
platform, you can really
build an integrated AI solution
with our Cloud IT platform.
Now, let's look at Edge TPU.
And to tell you
more about Edge TPU,
and the motivations for
building Edge TPU chip,
let me invite my
friend, Olivier Temam,
who is the tech lead for Edge
TPU in the Google AI team.
Olivier.
OLIVIER TEMAM: Thanks, Indranil.
So good morning, everyone.
It's a real pleasure to
be here with you today
to talk about Edge TPU.
And actually, what we
want to do is not only
to present you what
Edge TPU is, but we also
want to explain why we have
developed Edge TPU Google.
And to do that, we
want to walk you
through the four key motivations
that you see on the slide.
So the first motivation
that we had is we
want to bring high-quality
AI to the Edge.
And by high-quality I mean
high speed and high accuracy.
So at Google we are
developing machine
learning models for Edge.
One of our flagship models
for image classification
is MobileNet.
And it's not a unique
feature, but one
of the nice things
about MobileNet
is that it's a highly
configurable model,
and you can easily trade more
computations for more accuracy.
So just to get an idea of the
relationship between the two,
let's look at this graph,
where you see on the x-axis
the computational
cost of running
one inference at
the Edge expressed
in millions of multiply-adds.
And on the y-axis,
you have the accuracy.
So if you're shooting for a
moderate amount of accuracy,
like 60%, you're going to
pay 60 million multiply-adds.
That's 120 million operations.
But if you want to bump
that up to 75% accuracy,
you're going to have to
pay 10 times that cost, 1.2
billion operations.
And that particular graph stops
at 600 million multiply-adds.
You can invest more computations
to get even more accuracy.
So the point here is that
the computational cost
of high accuracy is very steep.
And what we want to
do there in order
to sustain high-quality
AI at the Edge
is to deliver high performance.
But because this is also
about embedded applications,
we have to do this
at a very low cost
and, naturally, in a small
physical and power footprint.
And that was basically
the first charter
that we had with Edge TP.
So the second
motivation that we had
relates to what
Indranil just explained.
We are building an end-to-an
AI infrastructure, Cloud
to Edge, AI to hardware,
and the key goal
is to make it as easy as
possible for our customers
to deploy their AI-based
solutions by piggybacking,
basically, this infrastructure.
So it involves work
across the three stocks--
AI, software, and hardware,
naturally-- and as you
all know, we have already been
developing a custom AI hardware
solution for the
Cloud, Cloud TPU.
So by introducing Edge TPU,
the other thing we wanted to do
is to complement that
infrastructure, so again,
to make it as easy as
possible for our customers
to deploy their solution.
Now we think,
actually, Edge TPU is
going to bring a lot of value
to our customers in terms
of helping them
deploy AI at the edge,
but we also are developing
an open infrastructure
so we see Edge TPU
as only one option
that we are making
available to our customers.
And customers remain completely
free to choose any hardware
solution they want.
So the third motivation that
we had is more technical,
and it relates, actually, to
a fairly fundamental point
about custom hardware
design, which is actually
very often overlooked.
It's a simple one, but
it's very often overlooked.
And it's the fact that
custom hardware design
is all about
leveraging in hardware
the properties of the
algorithms, so in this case
AI algorithms.
So that can be a challenge
for hardware designers
because it means
they have to develop
a fairly intimate knowledge
of the target algorithms of AI
algorithms.
So that can be a challenge
for most organizations,
but for Google it can
also be an opportunity
because all hardware
designers have access
to abundant AI expertise.
And therefore,
they can know what
the latest trends
in AI, and that
can help them decide
what kind of features
they need to bring within
their hardware designs.
Now, that's one advantage of
having both expertise, hardware
and AI, within the same company,
but it's not the only one.
What we can do, and what
we're increasingly doing,
is that we can also go the
other way around and start
adopting AI algorithms
so that they work
as well as possible
under custom AI hardware.
And the last point is that
probably one of the biggest
misconceptions about
custom AI hardware
is that it's
primarily a hardware
task while, in fact, the biggest
difficulty is the software
layer, which you use to map
AI algorithms onto the custom
hardware.
So what we are
really striving to do
is to develop a holistic
approach across the three
stack, and in both
as a conviction,
but increasingly based
on our experience,
this is what is going to yield
the best results in terms
of custom AI hardware design.
Our fourth motivation
relates to this one,
to the one I just presented.
So it's not only that all
hardware designers have
to have access to the
latest trends in AI,
but it's also that AI is
evolving extremely quickly.
This graph that you see here
has been collected by colleagues
at Google AI, and it shows the
number of AI-related research
articles which have been
submitted to archive
over the past decades.
And the key message
here is that this curve
has an exponential,
basically, shape,
so there is just underlines the
very rapid progression of AI.
So that, again, can be both a
challenge and an opportunity.
It is a challenge
because, as you know,
the timeline of hardware is
very different from the timeline
of AI research, but it
can become an opportunity
if we learn to tackle in
hardware this rapid evolution
of AI.
If we do that, then
what is going to happen
is that the performance
of the custom AI hardware,
again expressed in
speed and accuracy,
is now going to progress more
or less at the same pace as that
of AI algorithms.
And as you can see,
that's very fast.
So one way to think about
it is that, increasingly,
AI algorithms are playing for
custom AI hardware more or less
the same role as
transistor technology
it's playing for general
purpose architectures.
And when we sat down
to design Edge TPU,
from the beginning we had
that objective in mind,
which is, how are we
going to tackle this very
rapid evolution of AI?
And what we've
designed is actually--
what we've created is
not just one design,
but it is a design approach
exactly for that propose.
That's also why, when we
think about the first chip
that we are presenting today,
even though it's achieving
a very good performance per
dollar ratio, which we think
is going to help disseminate
high-quality AI at the Edge,
we also think about it
only as a first step
in a long journey,
which is going
to be largely driven by AI.
And we are already
well underway.
We have our second design,
and we've already started
to work on the third design.
And at every step, what
we're going to do basically
is to improve the AI support,
improve performance and power,
and bring more functionalities.
So those are some of the
key motivations that we had
actually to design Edge TPU.
And now to present you
in more details what
we are going to provide to our
customers in the coming months,
I'm going to invite Ajay, who
is the Edge TPU product manager
to present you that.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AJAY K. NAIR: Thanks, Olivier.
Good morning, everyone.
I'm Ajay Nair, the product
manager for Edge TPUs.
We'll go over quickly
on what we're releasing
and how users can have access
to what's being announced today.
So that is the Edge TPU.
One thing to note here is that
the one cent that is shown
is indicative of the
size of the Edge TPU.
It does not indicate the cost.
[LAUGHTER]
Aw.
But in all seriousness, though,
when we were designing the Edge
TPUs, we were striving to
achieve very high performance
per dollar, and I'm
proud to say that we've
been able to achieve that.
Our goals have
been met, and we've
been able to do that at
a relatively low power
footprint and also
physical footprint
on how big the Edge TPU is.
And a combination of
the high performance
per dollar, low power, as well
as the low physical footprint
allows broad deployment of Edge
TPUs in multiple applications.
And it helps our goal
to democratize AI.
In terms of the
Edge TPUs itself,
the first generation that
is being announced now
and the roadmap is an
inference accelerator,
and the architecture
was optimized
for vision applications.
Of course, it's an accelerator.
It can be used for
multiple models,
but it was optimized for vision.
It can run concurrent
state of-- and what
we can do with an
accelerator at the Edge
is essentially run multiple
state of the art models
concurrently, for example,
on a high resolution video
without losing frame rate.
Right?
As an example of what
Olivier mentioned earlier,
the MobileNet V2, we can achieve
several hundred inferences
per second on the
highest accuracy
versions of those models.
So what we are announcing is
not just the hardware, though.
What we are trying to do
is bring the leadership
and the expertise that Google
has in hardware, software,
and AI, and combine those
into a solution which
customers can have access to.
So as Indranil
pointed out earlier,
we already talked about the
Cloud IoT edge, and the Edge
TPU, and how they interact.
We are adding components which
make use of our expertise in AI
as well as software.
So in AI, for
example, we will be
releasing at the time of
the product launch, which
is in October when early access
customers can have access
to this product, a set
of precompiled models.
These are going to be compiled
to TensorFlow Lite, which
is Google's open source
AI framework for the Edge.
And TensorFlow Lite
allows low latency
at small binary size for
your Edge applications.
We'll be announcing
models, for example,
that are MobileNet based
models and other architectures
as well.
And it will also be
integrated with ML Kit.
ML Kit is a beta product
that Google announced
a few months ago,
which has an SDK, which
allows users to have
commonly used AI
applications at the Edge.
And if you have
more complex needs,
ML Kit also provides
an API for you
to serve those models
onto your Edge devices.
The next step after
that is we would
enable transfer learning
on those precompiled models
that we are going
to be providing.
So what is transfer learning?
Transfer learning
is a method where
you can repurpose an existing
model which is made for one use
case and customize that
based on your own data
sets for your specific use case.
So that's a very
powerful method,
and it really helps because
the investment needed
from users in terms of the time,
the effort, and the expertise
in machine learning
is vastly reduced.
So the existing precompiled
models can be repurposed.
You can bring your own
data and reuse your data
for your specific
application needs.
In a future update, we will
also be releasing the TensorFlow
light compiler for Edge TPUs
so you can start your model
design from scratch.
We also want to make
it easy for customers
to deploy Edge TPU at your
applications, the idea being we
would like to be able to
envision your use cases that
serve your business needs.
And using the products that
we're going to be releasing,
you can iterate, and prototype,
use the models in your hardware
applications, use the
transfer learning function
to optimize those
models for your use case
and test it out in your system.
And when you're satisfied
with the results,
you deploy that in
your real applications.
And we're also announcing and
making available the Edge TPU
development kit, and there are
two versions of the Development
Kit, depending on where
you are in the ecosystem.
If you want a fully integrated
solution with the Edge
TPU connected to an SoC,
what we are announcing
is a system on module.
So what you see here
It has the Edge TPU
ASIC connects to a CPU
and also a crypto for security.
That module connects onto--
I'll take a break there.
The Edge TPU is that red square
that you are seeing there.
And this is to scale,
by the way in terms
of the famous one cent.
The Edge TPU SoM
connects to a baseboard,
and the baseboard
essentially expands
the I/O connectivity
options that are available.
So there's a whole
slew of connectivity
there that you have
USB-A ports, USB-C, HDMI.
There's a MIPI interface to
connect your camera onto it.
It's got a WiFi interface, an
ethernet, and a five volt DC
power to power the devices.
So if you need a fully
integrated solution,
this is what you use.
The SOC will have Android
Things preloaded onto it.
It can connect
onto the internet.
You can download the
precompiled models
that we mentioned in
the previous slides,
and you can run
inference locally.
It also will have the
IoT Edge solution.
So once you run
inference locally,
your application can decide
what to do with the local data
and also use IoT Edge
to load back the data
as you need back to the Cloud
for storage or retrieval
or for further analysis.
We are also announcing
the Edge TPU accelerator.
It's a USB-C form factor device.
And if you have an
existing system that
has a host interface
available, we
can just connect the Edge TPU
accelerator using the USB-C
onto your systems and
accelerate your machine
learning workloads.
So both of these solutions
have been designed internally
at Google with partnership
from external vendors
for different components.
It's been designed
by the Google AIY
team, which is a team within
the Google AI business function.
All right.
And to show some
functionality of the boards
and what we can do with it,
I'd like to invite Preston
onto the stage.
Preston is our head
of IoT solutions,
and he'll help us showcase
a quick example of what
the Edge TPU can do.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
PRESTON HOLMES: Great,
so as Ajay said,
let's take a look at
some of the performance
capabilities of Edge TPU.
So I'm going to
mostly be off stage
and run you through this demo.
What we do is we have two
systems set up here, one
with Edge TPU and one without.
And so we wanted to show
you some of the performance
differences as well
as how you combine
the inference on the Edge with
sending data to the Cloud.
So give me one second
to start up some things.
And actually, if
I could have you
guys come over here because
you are accidentally actually
in camera, not as planned.
So if you can come over
with the other folks
on the far other side.
So what we've got is we've
got two cameras set up.
AJAY K. NAIR: [INAUDIBLE]
PRESTON HOLMES: Yeah, just
your seats were in the frame.
So we've got two
cameras set up, and what
we're using are high resolution
cameras, high frame rate
cameras.
These are 1080p cameras filming
at 60 frames per second.
And you can see already that if
you look at the top frame, that
is a system without the
TPU, the frames per second
in which we're able to
compute and analyze the video
are already down 13
frames per second.
Whereas the frames
per second with TPU
are still at a very high
frame rate processing
of 45 frames per second.
Now, what I'm going
to do, I was going
to invite my colleague, Matt,
one of the IoT engineers
who helped us with
this demo, on stage.
And so you can see that,
as Matt walks onstage,
we've detected Matt.
We see him onstage,
and you can see
that already the frame
rates starting to drop
a little bit without the TPU.
Now, all of this
inference, all of the ML
that's detecting Matt on
stage is happening entirely
on the Edge.
So we're not able to
realistically stream
this kind of high frame
rate, high resolution video
directly to the
Cloud, so we need
to be able to compute on
this information that's
so rich strictly on the Edge.
But since we have
now some information
we're interested in, we
can detect essentially
some information about
what we're seeing.
So one of the
things is we can now
look at just the simple
metric of how many things
have we detected that we're
interested in in the frame?
And we may average this out
over five seconds locally
on the Edge so that we have a
simple metric that we can then
send to the Cloud.
And once we're sending
information in the Cloud,
we can start to visualize
in things like a dashboard.
So I have, starting out
here, a very simple dashboard
that I can just see that we have
one person on stage right now.
But as a few other
colleagues gradually
join Matt and we
increase that number,
we can start to look at
what that performance is.
So in this case,
we're not only going
to send just the
count of people,
but we're interested
in some more
information about
the performance
of the actual system here.
So I'm going to switch briefly
to the dashboards for a moment
so you can sort of see
what that looks like.
So here we're looking at
three pieces of information.
The top is the number
of objects detected.
The second graph
is the frame rate,
and then the third
is sort of a gauge
of the instantaneous frame rate.
And you can see
that, with Edge TPU,
we're still holding steady
at about 30 frames per second
of effective processing.
Now, this is not just one
model running per frame.
We're actually running a
complex set of cascading models,
so we're doing many
inferences per frame
to achieve the information
we're interested in.
And so as you can see, as
the number of people in frame
goes up, the inference really
starts to drop without a TPU.
And why does this matter?
Well, if you're
looking at something
like this very high frame
rate, high resolution video,
it lets us do a
couple of things.
One is it's letting us
detect that there are still
people who might be
very small in the frame.
Right?
So if you're thinking of looking
at, say, very small defects
on equipment, surface
defects, or small parts,
high resolution allows you
to still provide the machine
learning full information.
And we're not only
using high resolution
on the camera input side.
We're actually not extremely
downsampling that video
to feed to a model, so we're
able to feed high resolution
directly into the model
because of the computation
power of the Edge TPU.
And as these numbers
increase, you'll
continue to see frame
rate dropping on the left,
but we want to be
able to also show
why does a frame rate matter?
If we're losing frames,
what are we losing?
So this model is not
only detecting things
like the person on
stage, but we're
able to detect a
degree of information
about what their orientation is,
what their attention is looking
at, and we can count these
as essentially glances
at the camera.
Now, these are glances
that last only a moment.
And so if we look
now at the way we've
counted glances between
these two systems,
you can see that many glances
are simply missed by the system
without a TPU because
they're so momentary.
And if you think
about applications
of the TPU in places such
as high-speed manufacturing
lines or other places where
momentary information that
might exist in an acoustic
signal that will be
dropped or missed,
these essentially
act as dropping important
events in the system you're
trying to analyze.
And so as these systems
are unable to keep up,
you're essentially losing
critical information.
And again, all that we're
interested in on the Cloud side
here is these
counts and metrics.
We don't have a need to send
a complex or potentially
sensitive information
that's happening on the Edge
directly to the
Cloud for processing.
We can keep that processing
happening strictly on the Edge.
So thank you very
much, colleagues.
And with that, I will return the
presentation back to Indranil.
[APPLAUSE]
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
Thank you, Preston.
So as you can see--
where did I put the clicker?
Ah, there it is.
Thanks.
So thanks, Preston.
So as you can see,
with Edge TPU,
the number of inferences
and the inference
you can do at a
high frame rate is
much higher than what you
can do without Edge TPU.
And we've run multiple
models in this demo.
These models were internally
built within Google
just for the purpose to
showcase the capabilities
and the horsepower we
have with Edge TPU.
We don't plan to make
it publicly available.
But you can use in
your own model--
you can train your own model
using Cloud Machine Learning
Engine and then use
our Edge TPU where
you have a use case for such
high processing in a real time
analysis.
So as we started
working on this,
we've been also engaging
some of our early customers,
and the feedback
from these customers
has been really positive.
LG CNS, for example, has used
our Cloud Machine Learning
Engine and our Edge
TPU and Cloud IoT edge
on some of their
cameras to really
improve their
productivity by detecting
defects in their high, fast
assembly line real time.
So they're really excited about
using our integrated platform
to improve productivity
in their production line.
Smart Parking is one
another of our customer
who are using Edge TPU, and
also looking at Cloud IoT Edge,
and the overall platform
to really revolutionize
the parking experience
by pushing intelligence
to the edge with
the entire platform.
So we're pretty
excited with where
we're headed with
overall our Edge story,
and the positive feedback
from the customers
is really encouraging as well.
Now, we understand that four
when you build a platform,
and as we start offering
our Edge solution,
we really want to work with
our partners' ecosystem.
So we've started engaging with
a couple of our key partners.
For example, in semiconductor
companies such as Arm,
NXP, are working with us to
build the system on module--
with Ajay, as I
showed in his slide--
using the Edge TPU, which can
be used by other device makers.
We are also working with some of
our key gateway device makers,
such as Hitachi,
Ventara, Harting, Nokia,
NEXCOM, and [INAUDIBLE],, who
are evaluating our platform
to take those Edge TPU SoM
into their industrial gateway
so they can push the
intelligence to the edge,
and really offer it
to their customers,
and take it to the market.
We're also working with some of
the Edge computing companies,
such as ADLINK, Kelvin,
Olea Analytics, SmartCatch,
Tracks, who are building smart
solutions using our Cloud IoT
Edge software, Edge TPU, and the
overall integrated AI platform
for the Edge solution as well.
So we're working hard on
the partner ecosystem.
We're going to continue to work
with a lot of more partners,
and we're really
excited with the partner
response we have gotten so far.
So as you can see,
just to summarize,
we are really working towards
an integrated AI solution
with our Cloud IoT platform.
What you heard today
is our Edge offering,
so Edge TPU chip, which is
our high-performing hardware
chip for machine learning
inference on the device
itself, Cloud IoT Edge, which
is a software stack for running
machine learning inference
on your Edge device, which
is optimized for Edge
TPU, and can also
work when a device
doesn't have Edge TPU.
And this works seamlessly
with our Cloud IoT platform,
which includes Cloud IoT
Core as a managed service,
pops up Cloud Machine
Learning Engine,
and other services as well.
So we are very excited
with our integrated AI
solution with
Cloud IoT platform,
and we can't wait to see
where enterprise developers
and customers can build
with this platform.
So next steps-- we are
offering early access to--
this is an early access program
with Cloud IoT Edge and Edge
TPU.
You can sign up for
access on these sites.
You can either go to
cloud.google.com/iot-edge,
or cloud.google.com/edge-tpu.
And our plan is that
we will initially
give product access to select
customers, get their feedback,
and then by fall we'll
start offering the Edge TPU
board more broadly and to
collect more feedback so
that we can refine our platform
and really make it such
that it's seamless, and it's
integrated for our enterprise
developers and customers to
build integrated AI solution.
So with that, I really
want to thank you
all for coming over here.
We will be waiting here for
a couple of more minutes.
If you guys have
questions, you can
come on the side of the
stage and ask us questions.
But we're really excited
with where we are heading,
and thank you for your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]